the new wave of la rappers
that you've been behind from you know
the star the ruchi's and all these guys
it seems as if the politics don't play
into as
much as the older generation a lot of
these younger kids are working together
they don't it do
it does it's still some but it's amongst
them so it doesn't reach the the media
because it's still amongst that because
you'll see like one take jay working
with
it feels like most people i don't know
yeah the scene yeah the scene
okay the senior for sure they all
because they all went to school together
they all played sports together etc so
like
and low-key most of them are shout out
to t.k barron because that [ __ ]
got everybody song shout out to t.k
our baron is crazy but they
what i remember talking to um kailyn
about this [ __ ] and he was saying that
they just learned from the mistakes of
the people that came before them and
it's like oh well
if we could do this [ __ ] together like
ruchi and chuck are known for doing [ __ ]
together right
so you might see a z show but then you
might see ruchi pull up you're gonna see
the one take boys there
or vice versa and i think that that's a
beautiful thing
but it gets a little tricky when you
start involving the homies
and hang arounds and entourages and [ __ ]
like that
but for the most part i really commend
the newer generation for being able to
do that and
and and also a big big shout out to
draco too
i really i really like what draco the
ruler has done because he came
home and immediately started giving
verses to everybody who would take them
and i felt like that was a big move
especially being in his situation with
the drake record like he don't
necessarily have to do that right
but a lot of those people that he came
and was like he didn't bless him because
i don't want to say like he's demeaning
them but
i felt like what he was doing he made it
his d his point to come home
it's like no i'm gonna i'm gonna give
this [ __ ] away to everybody who want it
is it safe to say he's the hottest
rapper in l.a and blasts the hottest
artist in la
this get tricky no no no no no listen
i'm not gonna say that because guess
what if
ronnie rich i'm not excluding a global
superstar like roddy
okay and excluding kendrick lamar and
excluding
all i mean i'm talking about hot in the
streets of l.a
i mean you got a lot of people that's
hot in the street no i know but is
anybody hotter than draco
i don't know i'm not in the streets
independently got the drake feature
that's true cleared [ __ ] he got that
yeah but that's that's
that's that's also drake being drake
yeah like oh this guy's name is draco i
mean i think he [ __ ] with i mean
draco's music is
no i'm saying drake is one of the
smartest people to ever be 100
so i understand the way he moves and
what he does and why he does it so
i'm not going to say that that's 100
because of the drake
[ __ ] because the drake knows what he's
doing drake knows who to tap into
he knows what he's doing like that's not
by accident drake don't do anything by
accident right
um i don't know who's the hottest but if
i if i'm gonna bet my money on people
it's
it's a few people i better for sure
blast i mean well we already
you were you were the first guy you did
what year did you try to sign blast was
it 2018 2017
2018 i think some [ __ ] like that yeah
shout out to blast man
you ain't last is the guy bro
he's the guy he's the guy yeah yo i got
a i got a text from
from from homie terrace martin and he
said you were right blast is the one and
i was like i
knew it i [ __ ] knew because it's like
it's one thing to get to
get the streets it's one thing to be hot
in the industry but when you get
musicians
to be like oh this guy is [ __ ] fire
that's that's a different level to me
yeah i think uh you know the lac and it
seems like it's in a
as good of a place as it's been you know
i would like to see more integration
though
meaning nationally oh yeah yeah i would
like to see like
i know sweetie's from california but she
she's comes off like a national artist
so for her to have draco on her [ __ ] you
know
i thought that was kind of dope i like
to see like i love how dave east comes
and taps in with
people out here like i want to see more
of that type of [ __ ] yeah now dave
pulls up and it's fun i want to see like
rod wave
like [ __ ] with like one take jay right
or some [ __ ] like you know more [ __ ]
like that i mean shout out to quavo he
did the blue bucks clan record
yeah um i really like you know who i
really really [ __ ] with not from la but
i love fredo bang bro
oh i remember you putting me up on fredo
like i love fredo
he's a good kid man he's a good dude
yeah the top record is crazy